as the hammer and sickle descended above
the Kremlin on Christmas day in 1991
America breathed the final sigh of
relief the days of Duck and Cover were
officially over
for the first time in modern history One
Nation prevailed in nearly every domain
from military to economic cultural and
scientific and it wasn't even close
in the absence of an imminent threat a
worthy strategic rival motivating it to
put men on the moon Sprint faster or
invent the internet the United States
experienced a luxury without precedent
a choice
so secure was its territory so Superior
was its Navy and dominant its economy
that it could simply decide its future
did it want to buy with this lead the
ability to ease its foot off the gas to
right size its military for the new
lower level of danger
for a brief moment that seemed like a
real possibility
Bush senior spoke of a peace dividend
the productive redistribution of
resources away from the military
98 major U.S military bases were closed
between 1988 and 95. along with hundreds
of smaller installations saving
taxpayers an estimated 57 billion
dollars and the Total Defense budget
decreased or at least stayed flat
relative to GDP for all but one of the
next 15 years
by no means was America relinquishing
its dominance but it was recalibrating
then on September 11 2001 the decision
was made
this time definitively
good evening
today our fellow citizens
our way of life
our very Freedom came under attack
in a series of deliberate and deadly
terrorist Acts
rather than accept the unthinkable that
America like any country will always be
somewhat vulnerable George Bush
redefined the word safe
safety was no longer about making
informed risk reward trade-offs
since 9 11 safety in America means near
invincibility nothing less than zero
casualties with zero room for error
everywhere at all times
in military parlance this meant shifting
from a threat-based model in which we
plan and budget our forces based on
those of our enemies to a
capabilities-based approach in which we
strive for the ability to do everything
regardless of the actual threats
it didn't matter whether a hypothetical
attack was realistic never mind actually
advantageous to the attacker we should
be able to prevent it just in case
should two separate Wars ever break out
simultaneously the U.S military should
be able to fight both each with maximum
Force
thus after a brief 10-year intermission
this new unattainable definition of
safety allowed existing yet previously
disregarded threats like North Korea
Iran and Iraq to neatly fill the Gap
left by the Soviet Union
in fact because there were numerically
more of them to many people the world
felt even more dangerous
unlike the Soviets who Americans feared
for their strength real or imagined
these new threats were said to be
irrational and thus undeterable
the United States decided that it could
no longer afford to take its foot off
the gas given how fast the enemy was
approaching it had no choice but to go
full steam ahead using what lead it
still had just to maintain it
mere dominance alone spelled eventual
defeat instead Bush Jr endorsed a
strategic ideal that had long lingered
in American politics
Primacy
where dominance means having a stronger
military beating everyone else at the
game Primacy means being so far ahead
that you set the very rules of the game
not only can you defeat anyone else in
battle but you ensure that no one else
even has the will to fight in the first
place
Bush spelled this out clearly when he
said quote if we wait for threats to
fully materialize we will have waited
too long the US he said must maintain
strengths Beyond Challenge and since
there already were no Challengers nearby
this meant traversing an entire ocean in
either direction
the world is all too familiar with a
Fallout from this redefinition of safety
the war in Afghanistan Yemen Iraq and
long lines at American airports to name
just a few
but by far the most overlooked
consequence was Bush's withdrawal from
something called the anti-ballistic
missile treaty and to understand why we
have to go way back to the early Cold
War
for those of us born in the last roughly
50 years the only world we know is one
of mutually assured destruction an
obviously terrifying concept
but before mad there was an even darker
20-year period most either don't know or
prefer not to think about
a time when the United States was
seriously talking about winning nuclear
war
The Truman Eisenhower and Kennedy
administrations commanded significantly
larger nuclear stockpiles than the
Soviets giving them the theoretical
ability to knock out all their
opponent's forces before it had a chance
to respond
and because they suspected correctly
that this lead wouldn't last they felt
the pressure to use it before you lose
it
from this perspective that war was
inevitable a larger and preemptive First
Strike was actually safer and more
responsible better to overwhelm the
Soviets now than risk a global nuclear
apocalypse later on
for years not only were extensive battle
plans drafted for a preemptive attack
but many called for using everything at
once
later when the Americans conjured fever
dreams of a surprise attack from the
Soviets They concluded that although
one-third of the U.S population would be
killed Victory would be America's as it
would then be able to quote eliminate
the USSR as a world power
to the U.S military at the time nukes
were just a bigger faster stronger
version of the bombs they already had
as if all this weren't insane enough
civil applications were suggested for
nukes
Edward Teller a scientist close to
Ronald Reagan proposed such bizarre
plans as using nuclear weapons to widen
the Panama Canal and speed up industrial
mining
this was the Wild West for crazy Atomic
ideas
fortunately sanity ultimately prevailed
or more accurately the Soviets started
catching up and nuclear War began to be
seen as an unwinnable outcome
faced with the possibility that one side
might suddenly win the arms race by
building either enough weapons to
overwhelm the other or an effective
defense against them and feel the need
as America nearly did to use this
Advantage they came to an agreement
the 1972 anti-ballistic missile treaty
limited the defenses each country could
build forcing them to confront their
vulnerability
in the end the treaty didn't stop the
Soviets from building more weapons but
it did give both Nations an interest in
peace and that peace would last for the
remainder of the Cold War
the treaty even survived the fall of the
Soviet Union with Russia inheriting its
place
that is until Bush withdrew after 9 11.
leaving the treaty the president
explained would allow the country to
erect a shield protecting all 50 states
from nuclear missiles by intercepting
them on the way
the only problem was that it didn't
exist
in fact spoilers 20 years and many
billions of dollars later and America is
still not protected
in other words this was Bush announcing
America's intention to become
untouchable
this was him giving the world a heads up
that he intended to spend near unlimited
funds to ensure the U.S had no skin in
the game allowing it to intervene when
and where it pleased with no
repercussions
needless to say this did not go well
shockingly Russia and China and North
Korea didn't just shrug their shoulders
and admit defeat instead they responded
predictably with countermeasures
because military technology takes years
to develop it took nearly two decades
after Bush's withdrawal but we are right
now entering an arms race
America is racing toward invulnerability
and its adversaries are inventing all
kinds of new and wacky ways to get
through its defenses
there are a million such examples but
let's just start with the absolute
simplest
American missile defenses have failed 44
of their 18 tests between 1999 and 2018.
despite being quote scripted for Success
according to the pentagon's former
director of testing
knowing that his life is at stake
imagine that Kim Jong-un in a crisis
decided to throw the U.S the most basic
of curveballs a decoy
because intercontinental ballistic
missiles travel through space where
there's no air resistance even radar
reflective mylar balloons would be
difficult to distinguish from the actual
Warhead
what that means is that Kim Jong-un
could likely foil our Advanced missile
defenses with the right-shaped balloon
another tactic involves packing a dozen
or so nukes on a single rocket a
relatively cost effective way to
overwhelm America's defenses
on the more high-tech side there are
hypersonics
while a traditional ballistic missile
travels up and down on a predictable
trajectory Hypersonic missiles Glide all
over the place making them far far
harder to intercept both China and
Russia have already developed this
technology and could even fire them over
the South Pole bypassing America's
defenses in Alaska
none of these countermeasures are
technically insurmountable
given the size of its budget we can
expect the U.S military to eventually
overcome them
the problem is that this is not an even
playing field
shooting bullets is just easier than
intercepting those bullets with other
bullets
by the time the U.S fills a loophole at
least one of a half dozen of its enemies
is likely to have found a new one
Russia for instance recently tested a
nuclear-powered cruise missile with
virtually unlimited range that spews
radioactive exhaust everywhere it goes
in 2019 it purchased 30 giant underwater
drone Torpedoes capable of delivering a
radioactive tsunami to an American Port
undetected
these weapons just get crazier and
crazier
now the Pentagon sees in these new
Russian Chinese and North Korean weapons
evidence that the world is becoming
objectively more dangerous
proof that we need stronger defenses now
more than ever
but because its task is to implement not
decide U.S strategy the Department of
Defense has a blind spot
what it doesn't see is that these new
weapons are being developed in response
to America's Post 9 11 pursuit of
invulnerability
that our missile defenses are too weak
to actually protect us yet strong enough
to provoke our adversaries who spend
Pennies on the dollar to defeat them
that's in trying to make America
completely safe we're actually making it
less safe
even if we did manage to intercept say
an incoming North Korean missile or
defending missile would look nearly
indistinguishable from a nuclear attack
to someone like China or Russia
if Russia saw what could be a nuclear
warhead headed its way would it
immediately retaliate
probably not but probably isn't very
reassuring when we're talking about
nuclear war
In fairness it's no surprise that the
military pursues military Solutions
that's its Duty
the problem is that there are no checks
and balances
experts have had serious doubts about
missile defense since at least the 1960s
at one point even laughing off Soviet
attempts to build it as a waste of money
but when faced with a crisis whether
during the Reagan Administration in the
80s or bush in 2001 presidents have
found it politically easier to promise
something that can never be delivered
than admit vulnerability
rather than restrain the military
politicians enable it
then because their goal of total
invincibility is unattainable the
defenses they build inevitably fail
presenting them with a new problem
to be honest they think and admit that
the US is vulnerable would scare our
allies and embolden our enemies
in Truth The Institute for defense
analyzes argues that not even the
Pentagon likely knows the real
effectiveness of our missile defenses
they've been tested less than once a
year on average and only under the most
optimal conditions
thus they feel they have no choice but
to mislead the public
despite a 44 failure rate the Navy told
Congress in 2016 that it had high
confidence in its success and Bush
warned you fire were going to shoot it
down during a 2004 speech
similar claims go as far back as Reagan
Americans not knowing any better believe
them in one poll from 2000 for instance
58 percent of respondents assumed they
were already protected from nuclear
missiles
this overconfidence in turn leads the
country to pursue more aggressive
tactics
it's easy to dismiss Kim Jong-un as an
annoyance when you believe you're
bulletproof you might also feel less
urgency to solve the problem
diplomatically
meanwhile this dismissiveness makes Kim
Jong-un feel the need to assert his
earnestness
until and unless the US takes him
seriously he won't be confident he's
deterring an attack
in other words politicians scared of
being weak in a crisis enable the
military then trapped by their own
decisions both mislead the public who
adopt a more aggressive posture
finally that aggressive posture leads to
more crises completing the cycle
the point is not that America is to
blame for all of Russia or China or
North Korea's actions it isn't
neither does this have anything to do
with the war in Ukraine nor is this an
argument against all missile defense
when and where it actually saves lives
that's a different story
the point is that America can
effectively defend itself and its allies
even while maintaining its dominance
without pursuing policies that only make
it unsafe
there's no trade-off here between
protecting American lives and not
irritating evil dictators because our
missile defenses only make the world
more dangerous for Americans
the United States is in a strange
position
separated from all its adversaries by
the two largest oceans blessed with the
geography of success and spoiled with
Unthinkable wealth and influence it's
the only country in the world where
Primacy feels like a choice
the only one where Absolute Total
impenetrable security feels genuinely
achievable if only we fixed this or that
technical problem or spent X number of
dollars more
but the U.S has spent no shortage of
money 350 billion dollars by some
estimates and no shortage of time over
70 years
every modern president Republican or
Democrat has either endorsed pursued or
at least left untouched America's
missile defenses
the United States hasn't failed for lack
of trying
it's failed because the goal of total
invincibility is impossible
the problem arises when the
single-minded obsession prevents America
from noticing when it becomes
self-destructive
when our desire to become invincible
puts us in needless additional Danger
to resist this very human temptation to
seek Total Security is unthinkable
to admit vulnerability contradicts basic
military strategy and Common Sense
and yet the United States must
its refusal to do so is already
responsible for one of the largest
unforced errors in the history of U.S
China relations and it all has to do
with nuclear weapons in this new episode
of my nebula original series China
actually out now on today's sponsor
nebula I explain why China has one of
the most sensible and level-headed
policies towards nuclear weapons and why
that might be about to change this is
the sixth video in the series and you
can watch all of them plus get access to
dozens of other exclusives not to
mention ad free and early videos on
nebula the streaming platform built by
and for creators best of all access to
nebula is included at no extra charge
when you sign up for curiosity stream
for just 15 a year with a link in the
description on curiositystream you'll
find great feature-length documentaries
like this fascinating one catching up
with the kids who George Bush was
reading to when the Twin Towers fell
click the link on screen right now to
get both nebula and curiosity stream for
an amazing 15 bucks a year and go watch
my new original episode on nebula